be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
characters teams and concepts from
across the comic book industry and this
week we're counting down the top 5
things you probably didn't know about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe number 5
how our directors selected ever wonder
why it is that directors like Steven
Spielberg and the Coen brothers have
never directed one of the movies on the
Marvel Cinematic Universe well the
reason for this was revealed during an
interview with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe President Kevin Feige in
January of 2014 what Kevin Feige
revealed here is that the selection
process for directors is in keeping with
Marvel's filmmaking philosophy and I
quote you don't have to have directed a
big giant visual effects movie to do a
big giant visual effects movie for us
you just have to have done something
singularly sort of awesome what this
seems to indicate is that Marvel isn't
looking for blockbuster directors and
instead is looking for directors that
have that creative edge something that
can bring a uniqueness to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe number 4 Planet Hulk
and world war hulk you ever wonder why
so many Marvel comic fans cried out in
joy at the possibility of a Planet Hulk
event well the answer to this is that
while these Easter eggs were caught
almost immediately by fans of Marvel
Comics and Foley the dark world during
one of the first battles in the movie
Thor comes face to face with a giant
rock monster while defeated almost
immediately this rock monsters name is
Korg and while he appeared in the early
stories of Thor in journey into mystery
number 83 he also appeared in the events
of Planet Hulk and world war hulk as
part of Bruce banners warbound a team
that was forged through combat during
banners time on Planet Hulk in addition
to this guardians of the galaxy featured
a race of beings called the Siq Ahrens
operating as a paramilitary force of
sorts this race is home to the planet of
Sekar itself the same planet where the
events of Planet Hulk took place
number three namor the sub-mariner as
one of Marvel's oldest creations and
first appearing in motion picture
funnies weekly in 1939 the rights to
name of the Submariner have been a
source of debate and speculation among
fans of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
for years while a 2014 interview with
Kevin Feige states that models rights to
the character are far from clean-cut and
have seen from Iron Man 2 during its
conversation with Nick Fury a map is
shown regarding all of the superhero
shield is aware of with one of the dots
showing a superhero in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean the location of namers
home Atlantis and the Marvel Comics
number two comic book writers and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
while famed writer Stan Lee is known to
have a cameo in almost every film
involving Marvel characters whether they
be created by Fox with a Marvel
Cinematic Universe something you may not
have been aware of is that writers Joss
Whedon and Jeff lobe have had massive
impacts on the MCU itself while Joss
Whedon is best known as a director of
Avengers and Avengers 2 age of Ultron
comic fans also know him as the writer
of astonishing x-men from 2004 to 2008
Geoff Lok however has a far more
impressive portfolio with works under
his belt including spider-man Batman
Superman The Incredible Hulk Captain
America Cable Iron Man daredevil
Supergirl The Avengers and Buffy the
Vampire Slayer
Jeff lobe is the head of Marvel's
television and animation branch
overseeing the production of existing
shows and animated series like daredevil
agents of shield agent Carter and Doctor
Strange as well as future shows like aka
Jessica Jones Luke Cage iron fist and
the defenders
number one the house that Kevin Feige
built as the big man in charge of the
model Cinematic Universe Kevin Feige as
viewed by Marvel fans as the man behind
the plan what some of you may not know
however is that Kevin Feige actually has
no experience in writing Marvel Comics
instead Kevin Feige is the Ultimate
Marvel Comics fan initially working as
an intern for Laura Schuler daughter one
of the producers behind the x-men film
in 2000 Kevin Feige was hired on as a
consultant due to his vast knowledge and
Marvel Comics following his
contributions to the x-men film baaghi
was hired as a consultant for the
following films Sam Raimi spider-man
daredevil x-men 2 Hulk
The Punisher spider-man 2 blade Trinity
Elektra the Fantastic Four x-men The
Last Stand spider-man 3 Fantastic Four
rise of the Silver Surfer and Punisher
war zone with his contributions and
knowledge spreading by word of mouth MCU
founder avi arad hired Kevin Feige on as
president of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe operating with the information
that Marvel didn't own the rights to
create films using the Fantastic Four
the x-men or spider-man Kevin Feige
realized that Marvel did own the rights
of the entire roster of the Avengers in
the current films adapting the
characters from these lineups to the
silver screen in a way that drew
interest from both the general public
and comic-book fans Kevin Feige shape to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as we know
it today with that being said we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
will catch you guys later peace